All right, so let's say we want to try Alice's vertex cover a little bit smarter.
So let's look at Alice's vertex cover.
The main thing that happens, the key idea is that we're just going to try
every single possible assignment of a cover to the underlying graph.
So, let's say that graph, we might try this, this, and this
or we might try this, this, and this, or just this, or maybe all of the vertices.
The point is that we're not specifying an order to check the vertices in.
We're just saying check every single one.
What if we did though, what if we decided to check the vertices in order of size?
That is we're checking the covers with increase in size.
So first, we check a cover with zero vertices in it,
that is no cover at all then we check every cover with one vertex in it.
So let's say this one, then we check this one, then this one, and so on.
And after we're done with that, then we do every vertex cover with two vertices in it.
So this and this and this and so on, and we keep going checking all of the covers in increasing order.
That way, once we found a possible cover,
we know that that is the minimum possible cover and we can simply stop it.
Now, my question then is does this change how the underlying algorithm performs?
So let's go down the questions.
First, does the new algorithm on average checks fewer assignments than the original?
Second, does the original algorithm sometimes look through fewer assignments?
And by that, I mean, does it look through fewer assignments
than the original algorithm at least once?
Next, is the worst case behavior of the new algorithm in O-notation better than the original?
And similarly for the best case and the average case of the new algorithm
in O-notation, are they better than the original?
Please check all either true or false.